well good good morning everyone and I
would I know you have your coffee and
you have your nice stuff but there are
some really great seats right down here
for anybody who would like to come down
and take some of them
it's it's part of the experience you see
come on down
now I know
this being a major conference and all
that the folks here are the cream of the
crop in the developer community
isn't that correct
which means that
none of you would ever
tell lies to yourself about development
which
yeah well
the reality is that every human being
lies to themselves at one time or
another I hope you do it less than the
average developer
uh
app but
but if you spot
if you spot some examples of your own
self-deception well you can learn from
that and you may see things that other
members on your team do from time to
time and
you become a better developer if you
don't do that
one of our biggest problems in this
industry is communication good
communication if you're lying to
yourself or you're deceiving other
people too
so good communication is essential
here's one that I find is very very
common because as best as I can tell a
third maybe a half of the people in this
industry are just incurable optimists
now it's okay to tell yourself This Lie
the first time back when you're young
and inexperienced and you don't know any
better the problem is these people as I
say a pretty good size chunk of our
community that keep doing it
all the way through their careers in
some cases
and it's another case where if you're
just lying to yourself that I can get it
done in a week or two weeks then that's
not so bad
the real problem comes up when you tell
your boss oh yeah I can get that done in
two weeks and six weeks later
you're not done with it that that's
that's a problem so if if you find
yourself in this situation more than
once or twice you ought to be learning
from that about how to do a better job
of estimation because like it or not and
I know there are developers don't like
it estimation is a part of software
development
now I know there are some people in the
process Community who say well our team
doesn't do us to us we just work until
it's done
well the the business needs to
understand the costs of development is
it a hundred thousand dollars to create
this app or is it 10 million you can't
do cost benefit calculations if you
don't know the cost
so what happens is if you don't learn to
do estimation and it is a skill and you
can learn to do it we've learned over
the years that a very high percentage of
the time 85 or 90 of the time we can hit
within 10 or 15 percent of how long it
will take the there's always the
occasional unforeseen circumstance
but estimation is a skill that can be
learned with experience
and understanding of the technologies
that are involved but if you don't learn
that skill if you don't learn how to do
it
now you're putting yourself in a bad
situation because if you don't make an
estimate
somebody else will since the business
needs it
you risk running into this arbitrary
deadline
and the situation you've seen that one
where somebody somewhere in the
organization
uh you look at the project and think
it's going to take six months and that
person says well we've promised it to
the customer in two months
how many of you have been in some
parallel situation at some point in your
career okay that's 90 plus of the
audience and the rest of them are
nodding their head so yes that this is a
ubiquitous problem now
how do you meet that problem if somebody
else is going to try to impose a
deadline on you what do you do about
that well one of the more common lies
that developers tell themselves when
they find themselves in that situation
is well I will just try I'll work extra
hard I'll work 12-hour days we'll figure
out a way we'll get it done how what
percentage of the time does that
actually work to meet the impossible
deadline
any or what are your estimates
one percent that seems like a reasonable
estimate to me I might go as high as
five
but impossible deadlines are are
impossible almost by definition and so
if you lie to yourself that you can meet
it then you're going to find yourself in
trouble when you get to the point where
you didn't meet it
what what makes them do that well as I
said part of it is that the business
needs to know how much the software is
going to take but there are other
factors involved too
other other things that that drive this
impossible deadline thing
sometimes the tools vendors Microsoft at
the front of the pack tend to over
promise what their tools are able to do
and sometimes developers just don't
understand how software is developed
and then
some mediocre managers they don't know
what else to do
they give you an impossible deadline
because they can't think of any other
way to motivate you
well let's let's look at these in a
little bit of detail the industry hype
thing for example
a few years back I was talking to a
manager and he was asking me Billy I go
to these sessions at conferences
and they do a demo in 15 minutes and
build a whole application
they build an entire solution to
Something in 15 minutes but I go back to
my team
and they say oh
six months minimum we don't know how
long it will take
album here
and I drew this graph to help him
understand it's part of the psychology
of presenting
if you do Demos in a presentation you
have about 15 minutes of attention span
maximum from the audience
so that demo is never going to be longer
than 15 minutes
therefore it creates the false
impression that you can actually do
something useful in 15 minutes whereas
the reality is that every generation of
tools and Technologies we have are more
complex and take longer to figure out
how to make things happen
so the gap between what it looks like
and what the real problem is what the
real difficulty is gets bigger pretty
much every year
and then there is the they don't
understand this problem that managers
even if they used to write code uh 20
years ago what do they really know about
how you write code and the Technologies
you use today
you might as well be back there in the
in your office or your cubicle stirring
a cauldron and saying magical spells for
all they understand about what you're
doing I particularly like the the
picture of the manager in this in this
thing the old bearded guy
who's looking on and wonder at what the
developers can do so they don't really
understand
how software development is done so they
don't have any way of making realistic
deadlines but they have to have a
deadline so they come up with impossible
ones now you should not give in to
arbitrary deadlines and that that is a
skill another skill to learn as you as
you grow and mature as a developer it's
tempting especially if you're the
non-confrontational type and a lot of
developers are it's tempting to go along
with the arbitrary deadline
to try to come up with a way as I said
I'll work 12 hours a day or whatever I
really think that part of your growth in
the industry is learning how to push
back on deadlines that you know you
can't meet
I think this is so important that I
actually have a question a standard
question that I ask in interviews I ask
in pretty much every developer interview
that I do
call it the Kobayashi Maru question
for those of you who have a bit of a
Star Trek background
basically I I pose to a developer the
following question you've you're in the
meeting
they've sketched out what it is the
Project's going to involve you've kind
of run your little estimation engine in
your head and you've come up with six
months maybe eight
and then of course comes the Zinger
the person presenting says and we've
promised the customer that they can have
it in two months
okay that's that's I I pose that
situation and I asked them what would
you do
now as as they say in the movie
as Kirk says
there is no right answer
this is a test of character
because whatever answer you give has to
be in connection with reality and honest
saying that you can meet the impossible
deadline is is not is is not doing that
um
anything that that implies that you can
get it done
is is not being honest with the person
that you're working with and you may
make them angry
but it's better that they get a little
angry now than a lot and angry later
when you have to come back and say you
don't have it and they have to go tell
the customer
now we get to a self-deception
that leads to lots of consequences
several of which I'm going to cover
in late 1990s
we changed the tone of this industry
with the Advent of java and then
later.net
you guys have no idea how Cobalt
programmers work did do you do you
realize that they read their manuals
after maybe working for a year or two
they probably never went back to the
manual except once a year
what percentage of time do you spend
looking up stuff that you've never used
before and probably will never use again
after you solve this problem
thirty percent fifty
more
thank goodness for stack Overflow what
would you do without it
so
we moved into an era we're figuring out
the apis figuring out how to write the
code that stitches everything together
was the the primary need in a developer
it didn't matter if if you didn't have
that it didn't matter how skilled you
were in other areas
you weren't going to be an effective
developer and that became kind of a
natural transition
two people thought well my job is to
write code
to figure to do the research to figure
out the apis and to write the code
that's what I'm supposed to do
well
actually your main job is not to write
code your main job is to produce
effective applications that have a lot
of value
but since you like to write code and you
got in the business because you're good
at it
the typical developer has a regrettable
tendency
to blow off
anything except writing code
and if you're going to produce valuable
applications
there are other things that are going to
be involved and you're going to try to
delegate those or not think about them I
put it to you that if you take into
account the other things that are
involved in making valuable software you
yourself will create more valuable
software and you will get recognition
and money out of that over the long term
in most companies
so don't feel like your only job or your
main job is to write code remember the
other things that are involved some of
you go even further by the way into this
problem
you basically become addicted to writing
code
it becomes a substance abuse problem
Code Heads cokeheads
one letter both groups do some lines to
get their fix
I mean this
this is
and I can I can tell you some of the
psychological signs
that you're in this group because as
best as I can tell it's a majority of
developers who do tend to pull things
off sometimes veering into addiction so
imagine this uh scenario you're in that
meeting I talked about earlier talking
about all the functionality you're going
to do for this next thing a new module
or a new feature or something that
you've got to write
and the meeting is to last 90 minutes
because there's a lot to explain
but after 10 minutes
you aren't listening to the person
explaining anymore
what are you doing
you're coding the solution in your head
or in some cases on your laptop right
there
think about that that is the sign of an
addiction you can't put it aside for 90
minutes
to listen to somebody about what they
need to do that's worse than smoking
as an addiction you can most people can
put cigarettes aside for 90 minutes
so
understand
that while cut writing code is important
and you have to be good at it in order
to be in the business
you can write absolutely perfect code
but if you haven't addressed the problem
that was supposed to be solved then that
code doesn't really have any value
and I see this in a lot of process
methodologies they talk about how fast
they can do code and we're going to take
something off the backlog and we're
going to get it done but I don't see
them addressing as much as they should
about is this the code I need to be
writing does this really add the value
that I'd like to to the applications
that I'm that I'm working on I have some
more to say about that a little later
one of the ways in which
developers tend to excuse themselves a
little bit from doing the stuff that
they don't want to do is they say well
I'm a coder I can't do design
well let me let me throw some cold water
on you if you happen to be
indulging in that particular bit of
self-deception
I I began my career as a developer
started writing code for money in 1978.
I'm coming up on 45 years next year
imagine that
and I switched in the
2007-2008 time frame
started gradually doing more design I've
taught my first class on design two
Developers
in 2011. and I can tell you that my
success rate
on helping Developers
to understand some of the basics of
design so that they don't produce the
incomprehensible stuff they produce
today
my the success rate's 70 80 percent
that that percentage of developers can
learn some of the basics that doesn't
mean you turn into a professional
designer but you can most of the stuff
that really matters in design is common
sense once it's explained to you and you
understand it and you form a habit of
using it that will make you create
better more usable more understandable
software for the rest of your career
most of you can do it I can tell you by
the way the psychological
characteristics
one major one of the developers who
cannot do it there are some developers
who just can't do design
and I can give you a feeling for
what what the typical problem is do you
know somebody in your life if you ever
associated with somebody that if they
thought
something should be this way they
preferred this they like this
that they couldn't understand why anyone
else would have a different preference
or opinion do you know people like that
those people suck at design
because their fundamental problem is
they can't go inside the mind of the
user and understand what the user would
prefer as opposed to what they prefer
so that's why you see so much software
that only a developer can figure out
because it's written by somebody who
does who who designs it from the
perspective of a developer instead of
the typical user
now if you do think that you're in that
that you can't do design one of the
things I want to point out is as the the
the myth that you hold in your head that
leads you to that self-deception is that
you believe
that designers are some special sort of
creature some colorful creature like the
flamingos in this photograph
and that the developers are more like
the turkey vultures looking on an Envy
now this is a false understanding of
what design is all about and who does it
so you shouldn't feel that way
a related deception that developers
sometimes indulge in is well designed is
about making the app aesthetically
pretty
and I don't have to worry about that we
have visual designers for that so we'll
just I'll delegate that to them I'll
just do whatever I want and and
leave it to them to fix things up
the problem with that
self-deception is that Aesthetics have a
definite limit
in how far they can go to fixing a bad
application
makeup cosmetics don't change the
underlying reality the thing if the
thing you built is a pig the visual
designers can put as much Cosmetics on
it as they want and it's still a pig
so
you don't have to learn to do visual
design but you need to understand design
that does promote usability and
understandability for for the users
that's kind of that's what my workshop
today is about
in fact Aesthetics taken too far
actually damage the value of an app
if the Aesthetics are too garish and too
obvious
then the application is like it's trying
to draw attention look at me I'm cool me
I'm one of those windows 8.
those Power Ranger colors that they had
there
well we know what happened to Windows 8.
and one of the reasons that it did is
that they they over emphasized some of
the Cosmetic design we're going to be
clean we're not going to have anything
on the screen except the app yeah well
then how do you figure out how to do
other stuff
let's go on to uh another Corollary
of the code addiction problem
we all write business rules but as I
said we spend a lot of our time probably
the majority figuring out all those apis
so what percentage of the code we write
are is business rules
what do you think 10 20
somewhere in there
because we well it varies of course with
from developer developer and and
application to application but we spend
a lot of time just getting Plumbing
stuff right
well as a result since that's our habit
and that's our preference that we like
to write code then there's a tendency
that when the business roles rules come
up that we just we just write more code
for the business rules Now problem
number one is that we mix that in with
all the plumbing code you guys have
learned not to do that right you know to
try to find a place to separate the
business business rules out the code for
that but
you don't really want a lot of business
rules to go into code
because we live in a very Dynamic world
patterns that were set
back in the 90s typically is that we we
put business rules in business object
Frameworks or something and that had the
assumption that those business rules
were pretty static
because you don't put things in code
unless it's static if it's Dynamic and
needs to change all the time well you
don't want to have to Loop in a
developer a coder every time that a rule
changes
here's an example date of elevation
I work in healthcare apps a lot
and there are different insurance
companies involved typically
so what that means is when I bring up a
particular patient or a particular
facility or something the rules for data
validation are going to be different
depending upon the insurance company and
some of the other inputs to the system
and I'm going to be constantly adding
new insurance companies
and new rules
so that means that the validation rules
have to should be dynamic they ought to
be somewhere they can be configured
metadata in a database somewhere or
something and then have some engine
engine to interpret and enforce them
so that's actually another question I
ask in developer interviews I pose the
problem of data validation and explain
if you are in a situation where
the the rules for validation are not
static they're highly Dynamic how would
you how would you construct that or have
you done that and it's surprising how
the percentage of developers I talk to
who have never written a dynamic
validation architecture before even
though it's sadly needed in most of the
applications that we do so you should be
thinking about business rules in terms
of how can I make them external to the
code insofar as that is possible
your natural tendency based on your code
addiction will be just dump them in code
that's also the fast way to do it in the
sense that that gets it done today
and then
just keep doing that over time and
you're building up technical debt
because you've got all these static
rules and what happens when the person
who wrote those static rules is gone
who goes back and figures them out
unwinds all the spaghetti
to figure out how to maintain them
another example of trying of needing to
put things in in metadata and not encode
that I say is workflow almost every app
I run into has workflow in it
unfortunately most of that workflow is
clooged up in code somewhere
instead of
instead of coming up with some kind of a
framework that will help you construct
workflow and look I excuse you on this
one I really do
because Microsoft can't get it right
either
they didn't get workflow right in this
talk
they didn't get it right in Windows
workflow one so they dumped that started
over and they didn't get it right in
Windows workflow too
and they're currently in the process of
not getting it right in logic apps in
azure
so this is this is a a hard problem to
solve but it's quite solvable
um basically the uh what you need to do
is stop thinking about workflow in terms
of code see that's where Microsoft goes
wrong
they always think about workflow in
terms of code because they think about
everything in terms of code
they're an extreme example of some of
the code addiction problems that I
talked about you folks have
as in essence if you're going to do
workflow what you're going to have are
work items that need to be processed
worked on you're going to have cues on
them where they're being held until
somebody is ready to work on them and
then they go to another queue perhaps
when that phase of the workflow is done
and you need a central place to put all
the rules for processing the atoms and
routing the items from Q to Q those are
the three essential things for a general
workflow system
and Microsoft's none of Microsoft
Solutions have any of them and most of
the applications that I see when I go
into for people to uh
um to look at their apps they don't have
them either
well
let me explain the power of this from a
real example we wrote this system my
team wrote this system in 2004 for
handling of prescriptions
about 5 000 pages of facts came in in
the morning and at the at the end of the
day boxes went out on a FedEx truck that
was that was their business model
well there's all kinds of things that
have to happen in the meantime
we have to order order this thing
enter the orders from the faxes or take
the orders from the web app which is
what we changed it to there are refills
there are regular prescriptions there
are approvals There Are Places to pick
the drugs there are places where you mix
up special drugs there are places where
you check to see that all the drugs have
gone in the box that need to go in those
are cues of work that needs to be done
we thought we had about 20 cues and so I
I developed a general workflow system to
handle the cues it turned out when we
finished the app 43 cubes 43 areas of
work but adding a new area
was a matter of adding a little bit of a
couple of Records to a database and
typically 15 20 maybe 50 lines of code
to do some of the routing and processing
so we were able to do that very very
quickly that was the valuable part of
that app
when that company was bought one of the
main assets
that the buyers
said was was the reason for buying it
was that this system would allow them to
put this kind of of of workflow in all
of the the rest of their operations too
now let's uh
let's go on to something that I it's not
as bad now as it was six or eight years
ago but but I still see it a lot
remember
the people you work for mostly don't
understand what you do we've already
been through this
so
as a result I don't really know how to
motivate you either
and and this problem's been around for a
long time I I got a new boss
1993 I think
and um
he was looking over all my work and all
the stuff I did and I had my hands on a
lot of stuff
and he said well I think that you don't
get enough recognition
and I said well I agree understand
though I prefer the kind of recognition
that I can deposit in my bank account
well managers don't like to throw money
around
so one of the things they do throw
around is job titles and in our world
that means that a lot of people end up
with architect in their title
well having that in your title doesn't
necessarily mean you do architecture I
think it should be reserved for people
who do but I've lost this battle
let me explain to you how badly I've
lost this battle
there is a major bank and I won't name
them by name it's because I don't like
slamming them but I was I was told this
story both by an Insider and by somebody
else who did some some work with them
and and would you care to guess how many
people they have in their development
area that have Architects somewhere in
their title
2 000 people
in that organization have architect in
their title how much actual architecture
do you suppose is being done
I I'm thinking of making a sci various
Billy's laws
I'm thinking of adding one to the list
that the amount of architecture actually
done in in your organization is is
inversely correlated with the number of
people that have architect in the title
because doing see
the answer for a lot of people they
don't know how to do real architecture
so what they do what we're doing micro
Services now microservices are okay
but don't make the mistake of thinking
that their architecture
they're because you're not really
thinking through the big picture and
understanding how they all relate to one
another you're doing them individually
and granularly and retconning them when
when you have to to make them work with
the other stuff that you produce
researching apis is an architecture a
lot of development teams have people
whose primary job is to kind of look
into the future see what technologies
are coming figure out the apis of them
write proofs of Concepts so that you can
kind of understand whether or not
they're going to apply to the team's
particular problems
but that is not architecture
it's research I don't know what else you
would call them but researcher or
something but it isn't architecture so I
have never even though I do quite a lot
of architecture I've never had architect
in my title and I never will because I'm
a generalist I do lots of things but if
you want to specialize in architecture
you want to really do it there are some
great resources out there one of them is
the book writing software which is I
think a little over a year year and a
half old by the brilliant yuvalloy how
many of you know you've all you've
worked with me at some point I see about
six or eight hands there uh often
considered to be one of the foremost
experts on software architecture in the
world teaches a master class on it so
you can you can go take a look at his
book if you'd like to get started down
the path of doing real architecture
instead of pretending that you do
architecture
as somebody who does both development
and Design This is a self-deception
that I feel particularly strongly about
and I am indebted to Alan Cooper you
know who that is
the
coined the term interaction design one
of the most foremost interact
interaction designers in the world he
retired a while back but
um the inventor of the drag and drop
development environment he created what
became the original Visual Basic you use
his designs today if you use Visual
Studio Visual Studio is the great great
grandparent it's grandchild of that
original Visual Basic
I was speaking at our Microsoft patterns
and practices conference he was doing
the Keynote and he and he put He talked
about this he said when people say they
have to build something to show to the
users it's a cop-out
and that emboldened me
because I believed it already
I just thought well you know is is that
opinion really well one of the most
foremost people on design in the world
believes it also and I thought through
it some more and kind of realized
what the real story is and this is my
own take on it this is not his but this
is the way I look at it
and the reason that I didn't ever think
that that was the reality that you
couldn't figure out what to what users
wanted without building something to
show is because I I had never done that
I had done design I had done prototyping
I had done various things to iterate my
way to designs that would work
and it's a skill
it takes time and effort to learn how to
do it but if you claim
that you must build something that
that's just the only way to do it you
must build something to show
to see what the users need
what you're saying what you're admitting
is that because you can't do it you
don't think anyone can do it
well it's kind of an arrogant attitude
isn't it
it's a skill and you can develop it you
can learn how to do it it is it is an
interesting skill and a discipline and
it takes time now
let very often there's a
misunderstanding here when I talk about
this subject which is that well you but
users can't design screens no they can't
they can't
they can't design screens anymore than
people who go to a movie and don't like
it can write a screenplay for a better
movie yeah that is understood that's not
their job but what they do know
is their job
they understand what they have to do
every day when they come in they
understand the steps they have to go
through the information they have to use
to accomplish those steps those things
are all up there
the skill you are developing is the
skill of talking to them and asking
questions and listening until you
understand that and observing observing
their their jobs
and you have to learn how to do that
developers typically don't
don't get into the business because they
enjoy that sort of thing but it's not a
huge percentage
of the work that you need to do it's a
small percentage at the beginning that
pays enormous dividends all the way
through a development project
if you really understand what users need
you will actually be a faster developer
because you won't have to stop and think
about should I do it this way or that
way you'll understand their job well
enough to match what you're doing to
that to that job
now one of the skills
one of the sub skills involved
in learning how to draw out of users
what they do and how you can address it
is listening and this is actually this
is a skill that is in short supply in
the entire human race as best I can tell
in fact in fact
some research has been done on this
I want you to think in your mind about
how long
the typical person does active listening
in a conversation before their attention
wanders
any estimates
anybody got an into intuition about that
30 seconds is not a bad estimate but the
research says 15.
and you've seen this you've been talking
to somebody and they're they're looking
at you and
you know they get that glazed look on
their face
which means their mind is going
somewhere else and they are pretending
to listen to you
how many of you have seen that at some
point in your interactions
come on I'm gonna come on I know it's
more than that
that's virtually all of you isn't it
so if you can see it in other people
they can see it in you too and you have
the problem unless you've worked on it
or you happen to have an unnaturally
high level of talent in listening now
this book right here the Charisma is
written by
um a woman named Olivia Fox Cobain she's
just she's absolutely brilliant in the
field of how you interact with other
people to establish credibility and
presence and she has an entire chapter
in that book on listening she has
exercises you can learn to get that
period of active listening up to about
90 seconds and then with a very short
sort of reset you can do another 90 Etc
you can learn to do active listening and
active and and take take in what people
want to communicate to you
and it helped me will help you in all
aspects of your life
you don't just do this because you want
to talk to users
your spouse or significant other
may very well notice the difference
when you are able to listen more
effectively and more attentively so
that's um that's a skill that I would
recommend just
for for your whole life but it
particularly applies to to understanding
users and being able to figure out what
they do so that you can match what the
software you produce to their jobs and
their lives
here's what I like to put in just
because I do have done traditionally a
fair amount of interviewing of
developers to fill out members of the
team for whatever reason that became a
pattern back about 20 years ago is that
I would go in as a consultant but the
person running the team would ask me to
to participate in interviewing
so I've done I've interviewed hundreds
of candidates
and back in the 1990s
as I was doing this a lot I started to
develop my list of questions to remind
myself of things
that I should ask them but in fact most
Developers
get involved in interviewing
pretty much by accident right see the
problem is that HR can't do it they have
no clue how to figure out whether a
developer is is for real or not
so they delegate that to somebody in the
technical area
but then
they don't prepare you for it you
probably don't prepare yourself you got
a job so you just kind of walk in and
wing it
what that often turns into is a certain
amount of socialization that you that
the primary thing you do is just chat
with this person and that's kind of
understandable because of the nature of
who we are as a group as a tribe if you
like
I mean how many of you does your mom
know what you do for a living and
understand it
practically nobody see we look at the
world differently
because I guess because we talk to
computers More Than People whatever the
reason we tend to look at the world a
little differently we're kind of a tribe
and when we meet somebody else in the
tribe we want to socialize with them and
kind of do a little bonding with them
because we don't see that many of them
so that's what the an interview often
degrades into is just some socializing
well socializing is important somebody
does need to be a cohesive member of the
team they need to fit in
but it's it's really down the list of
ways in terms of priorities of whether
or not they will actually help your team
produce valuable software
so instead it's really good if you will
prepare so that you understand some of
the things you're going to ask and some
of the techniques for Effective
interviewing this is another skill
fortunately this one isn't that hard to
um to get having the questions is the
big thing so here's an example of a
question think back to a system you
worked on five years ago if you were in
charge of redeveloping that system today
what would you do differently
think about what that tells you in their
answer
the obvious stuff is do they keep up
with technology so they know how things
would be done differently today
but this also helps you understand is
that person defensive about their work
because I find defensiveness about about
coding is almost perfectly correlated
with poor Developers
so I I sort of look for that that
defensiveness and the um the document
I'll show you a link to it in a minute
so you don't have to photograph there's
20 something questions I can't show them
all
um
there are examples of answers that I
really am not satisfied with and answers
that I think really understand help make
me believe that that candidate
understands things
here's another example question and this
turned out to be the most popular
question in my entire list I I had a
woman stop me after about three years
after seeing me do a session on this she
stopped me in the casino in MGM Grand in
Las Vegas to talk to me about this
question
because it was her by far her favorite
question she was a manager of a team of
Developers
what's the weirdest bug you've ever
encountered
how did you solve it
now I usually preface this question by
talking about my own weirdest bug
and give them a little bit of time to
think about it as well as understand the
context of the questions I'm asking so
the weirdest book I talked about was
this was
1996 I think we were just about to put
out a system in Visual Basic for how
outcomes measurement in health care and
it was in final testing and it seemed to
be doing fine except that randomly
a dialog box would come up that said
false
okay
well it didn't seem to have any effects
but you know people are going to call
tech support
if they see it so we got to figure that
too a couple people went through it
didn't solve it landed on my desk
and I you know did the usual sort of
analysis got all the the message box
statements
started throughout the ones that had
more than one button
Etc eventually did discover the problem
which was a single character the person
constructing the message for the Box
put an equal sign where they should have
put a plus sign
because that's the same key on the
keyboard
just the lack of a shift but if you say
string equals string and the strings are
different what result do you get
false
so that was my weirdest bug and and if
you ask people this question and and you
get an idea of how how deep are is their
experience really because if you've
really been doing development at an
intense interesting level for a long
time you're going to have an interesting
buck
strange book that you ended up solving
and when you when they explain how they
went about solving the bug now you get
an understanding of of their their
thought process how do they analyze how
do they think about things both of which
are very valuable for judging candidates
and questions for both Tech skills and
soft skills and I mentioned the
Kobayashi maroon thing already that I
asked that in interviews that's an
example of a soft skill question
if you want to go deeper on this I have
a course on LinkedIn uh with that bitly
link and you can if you have a LinkedIn
subscription you can watch that or you
can just get the list of questions at
that second link there if you just like
to go through the questions and use them
the the video
includes a lot of techniques I use
during interviewing how I analyze
resumes and things like that
all right
boy developers in general I find are
very vulnerable to this one
in my design classes I talk about this
that um
one of the most dangerous phrases in
this industry
is wouldn't it be cool if because we
love cool technology don't we and we
look for reasons to put it into our
into our projects
at the extremes you can end up with
messes like this one
this you can see the bitly link for the
article here where they went through the
problems in the F-35 fighter jet program
now some of those problems will be
completely familiar to you
they had like eight or ten times the
amount of code of the previous
um that the previous fighter jet it
didn't have good architecture it was
bloated so it had lots of bugs so the
article talks about that it talks about
other things
but one of the things that it talked
about that just jumped right out at me
was how the entire cockpit's based on
um touch screens
including a lot of the switches to make
things happen
but the problem is you gotta look at
touch screens to make sure you've
actually flipped that switch it has no
tactile feedback whereas fighter jets
are used to these physical switches
that they touch they know where it is
they don't even have to look they know
where it is they flip it they know they
flipped it now if you're a fighter pilot
how would you feel about having
touchscreen switches switches that about
20 percent of the time you're not really
sure whether you've flipped them or not
that's that's kind of a life affecting
situation there isn't it so the the
pilots really didn't didn't like this
and so because of the option of times
they didn't work
um some of the people in the program are
saying we just need to scrap the F-35
and start all over with a new fighter
jet after spending a trillion dollars on
it
I don't I don't think you will ever have
a failure that big I hope you don't
I hope you don't come within a couple
orders of magnitude of that but
I can just imagine the meeting where um
where somebody said yeah you know we're
building the Next Generation
fighter jet and touch screen
mirable and we can swap out the software
yeah um yeah
and I don't know why I picked this
picture somehow this just sounds like
the the kind of meeting where they would
make that decision just feels that way
to me
and that striving to be cool also
applies to the whole Windows intensity a
Windows 8 situation that they wanted to
compete with the iPad and the iPad was
con was was considered cool it was
perceived as cool by a lot of people and
it was cool but it wasn't cool because
it tried to be cool
if you try to be cool you're probably
gonna fail at it did you go to high
school with somebody who tried too hard
to be cool
did they manage to be cool
oh that wasn't you for any of you
all right so no no don't don't try to be
cool you're virtually guaranteed to fail
uh and and and good design good good
apps
um are typically transparent that they
just people just use them they don't
think about how cool they are
oh I just love my process X everybody
should use it
look if you have a process that works
for you I think that's wonderful if it
helps you get software out faster
then that's good I am not dogmatic about
processes if you find one that works
that's great for you but this world
varies so much developers vary companies
vary applications vary
Technologies vary
so the idea that one process would work
for just about everybody strikes me as
pretty silly but there are people in
this industry who believe it they love
their process they are emotionally
involved
with their process you've no doubt met a
few of these people
and I hope you're not one of them but
you know you probably FIB to yourself
you probably deceive yourself if you are
let me give you an example
this is the original work on scrum
by a couple of Founders schwabber and
Beetle and this sentence appears on page
one
industrial process control theory is a
proven body of knowledge that describes
why scrum works and other approaches are
difficult and finally untenable
that is a long-winded way of saying
scrum works and nothing else does
if you strip away the irrelevancies in
the fancy words in that sentence that's
what it means now later in the book he
kind of walks us back a little bit but
just the fact that he would even put
that sentence there and the first page
trying to describe this just it was a
big red flag for me when I read this
book and was looking to get into scrum
now I work with a lot of different teams
I've worked with teams who do you scrum
and kendan and other forms of agile and
as I said if it works for you that's
fine I've worked with teams that don't
have any recognizable process and they
get software out successfully so I'm not
going to argue with them either and try
to convert them into doing a process but
but I personally based on this never
developed any affinity for scrum because
if you say this I as far as I'm
concerned you're just a fool
the real world doesn't work that way
and
while as I said I don't care if you use
something and you like it and certainly
there are teams that use agile very
successfully there are also it's the the
hype around it and the the
the industry of trainers and consultants
and and certification Stuff Etc
leads to some incentives to over promise
what it's capable of doing and that has
been noticed this came out I don't know
two three years ago five years ago it's
been that long
um UK wasting 37 billion a year on
failed agile projects now if you talk to
an agile Aficionado they'd probably say
Well they're not doing agile right and
you know what that's they probably are
correct about that but if you're
philosophy Etc is so hard to get right
that 53 of cios in the UK consider it
discredited then you got work to do okay
don't don't keep over promising the same
old stuff
so don't deceive yourself into thinking
that a process will just solve a
dysfunctional team's problems it
probably won't and that's really what
these cios are reflecting is that they
were that they were not getting the
results they wanted from their teams and
they were promised that this would fix
it
and that's an over promise so don't
deceive yourself into thinking that
processes are the ultimate answer
to some of the problems we have in
software development I understand where
agile came from remember I talked about
this
we moved into this area where there's
all these apis constant research Etc the
enormous crushing complexity
older ways of doing software did not
deal well with that
and agile came in and added some
accountability and some um it's tried to
work into the the iterative nature of
solving problems and to that extent the
imposing accountability and getting
feedback about how things are going are
important and most agile processes do a
pretty reasonably good job of that but
don't take that to be the magic solution
to everything
the biggest problem though that I have
with with agile when people talk
themselves into leading is the kind of
the ultimate thing ultimate uh way of
looking at software development
is that agile tends to be code Centric
and granular
so everything's kind of feature based
and the problem with that is
good software matches the user's job
which means it's focused around the
user's workflow it's not focused around
features imagine all the think of all
the software you know
think about the menus they're all sort
of Collections and features
that's that's what the menus come out of
is the structure of the data and the
features that are in the app that's not
the way that apps ought to work apps
ought to correspond to people's jobs
they'll they ought to be based around
people's workflow
and so but but coming up with Innovative
work workflow is hard when you're doing
things at a very granular level you have
to step back and do big picture thinking
in order to do that
and that granular feature and and
individuals tiny user stories doesn't
really Foster the big picture thinking
and I again this is understandable and
and look we've only got so many hours in
the day
and I understand why people fall into
this and convince themselves that it's
the best way or maybe the only way to do
things but the more time you have to
spend coping with the complexity the
less time you have for Big Picture
thinking but you ought to be forcing it
in there anyway because it it's it's
extremely valuable
I'll give you one one example we're just
about done here so it's a good example
to kind of understand the value of
innovation
this piece of software here is from 3n
it is for Radiologists to produce
reports based on MRIs and x-rays and
things
um myself and one of my other team
members went to help 3M design it back
in 2010. at that time a radiology report
basically looked like it came off a
selectric typewriter
and there's this there's this language
that says in the upper medial blood you
know whatever that's that indicates the
portion of the image that they're
talking about
well if you just kind of did
feature-based stuff reproduce the old
stuff to a new Radiology system okay we
produce the Radiology report the way
it's always been done
but I I like to call myself the asker of
inconvenient questions
I asked the question
why can't we just grab a piece of the
image and drop it into the report
because we got the technology to do that
now 2010 we had the technology for that
and the look on people's faces like you
just never never even thought of that so
you get yourself into ruts in the
applications you build you you think of
the way that they're done now as the way
to do them
and dropping back to Big Picture
thinking which your processes today do
not encourage is the way to question
assumptions and and and do some
significant Innovation and that
particular Innovation uh resulted in the
3M move from being a second tier player
with their old windows forms app to one
of the leading players in that industry
400 million in sales in the first five
years they've probably by now sold about
a billion dollars worth of that software
and the reason they're the market leader
is that they innovated
all right final one
I know better than management what to do
look
here's the problem that's not entirely
necessarily
of self-deception
because you might know better I mean
we've already discussed the fact that
your managers don't really get a lot of
what you do or how software is developed
so you might very well be in a position
to make a better call than them but
it's not your job and they know things
you don't know they know aspects of the
business
Etc that you may not be aware of so when
you think you know better
I would consider it your responsibility
to make a case
for why you think why you think you have
something better
and that's fine
but but if you in the process of trying
to make that case and influence the
manager now you don't give them the full
story you don't you tell the good things
about your your ideas and you don't get
into the bad things and the constraints
that's going too far don't do that
you're fooling yourself if you do that
you are taking somebody else's
responsibility upon yourself without
telling them that
and I don't regard that as
um I don't regard that as proper
all right so to wrap up then
Clarity is the key to so much in
development so don't deceive your users
or your management or yourself
don't don't be addicted to coach try to
work on that so that you don't fall into
the traps the self-deceptions that come
out of your preference for code build a
whole stack of talents instead and as I
said learn learn to listen okay we have
about three or four minutes I think
for questions
either either I was incredibly Lucid or
you didn't get anything that I said
because you've got that shell shock look
on your face yeah
yeah
okay the question is uh many especially
larger organizations tend to have a
layer that
um whose job it is to go work with the
users
and and some of them are kind of touchy
about you getting involved with that
um the problem with that is they're not
developing the software you are and that
means that you need to have the
understanding too it doesn't mean you
necessarily need to drive the process
of understanding but you need to
participate in it you need to see users
too you need to understand the the
results that they produce and some of
these people produce just simplistic
user stories that have no depth to them
that that is very common so when we go
in it's we don't accept we simply don't
accept it when we go in and somebody has
presented us you don't need to talk to
the users because we have this wonderful
stuff
that you can use
um well see I have the luxury
being the consultant
the guy that comes in from a long way
away
and so I get to say well I'm talking to
the users if you don't want me to talk
to users that's fine but then I don't
need to be doing this work because I
can't form the understanding just by
reading what somebody else has to say
about it we've we've seen all the
studies about how communication drops
off with every layer
so that layer imposes a cost on the
understanding for the user and there's
no reason that they can't incorporate
you into the process we do it all the
time
so
yes they the next step is oh we're going
to have the meeting we're going to
interview the users in this conference
room setting
um that's not entirely valueless but it
does it doesn't accomplish the purpose
either the problem there the central
assumption that's wrong there is that
the users in that setting will assume
that everybody knows things that they
won't bother to say
you would see if you went and actually
watched them work you would see what was
actually going on
and those assumptions would be uncovered
but in that venue they won't be they
will think things that
um that they will think you know things
that you don't know
all right we got time for maybe one more
I think
and then we gotta get onto those
wonderful workshops
and I will be around all day today and
you can ask me more questions later if
you like any more
okay let's let's get a
that's from the audience before we quit
of the roughly 10
lives developers tell themselves what's
your personal account of how many you
saw that you go yeah I I do that come on
too many
anybody want to put a number on it
nope
don't be into eight okay
four four okay yeah as long as long as
you're being honest with yourself about
that number
you've taken the first step towards
stopping
stopping the the self-deception all
right folks this was this was a lot of
fun I hope you got some some good
interesting pointers out of it and says
I'll be around the rest of the day hope
to see a few of you in my workshop here
starting up as soon as I can
deconstruct and reconstruct in the other
room thank you so much
thank you